we're asked to rationalize and simplify
this expression right over here and like
many problems there's multiple ways to
do this we could simplify a little bit
then rationalize and then simplify a
little bit more or we could just
rationalize and simplify and just to
make sure that you know what they're
even talking about rationalize is just a
fancy word fancy way of saying we don't
want to see any square roots of numbers
in the denominator that's all it says so
try to get these things outside of the
denominator so the first thing that we
can do let me simplify a little bit and
then rationalize and then we could think
about other ways to do it so what i'd
like to do first is say well square the
principal square root of 8 that can be
simplified a little bit because 8 is the
same thing so that's is the same thing
as the square root of 4 times 2 which is
the same thing as the square root of 4
times the square root of 2. so we can
rewrite this entire expression as the
numerator is still the same 16
plus 2 x squared
all of that over we can rewrite this as
the square root of 4 over times the
square root of 2 and the square root of
the principal square root of 4 we know
is just 2. so square root of 8 we can
rewrite as 2 times the principle square
root of 2.
2 times the principal square root of 2.
and i've simplified a little bit i've
done no rationalizing just yet it looks
like there's a little bit more
simplification i can do first because
everything in the numerator and
everything in the denominator is
divisible by 2. so let's divide the
numerator by 2. so if you divide the
numerator by 2. 16 divided by 2 or you
could view it as we're multiplying the
numerator and the denominator by
one-half so 16
16 times one-half is eight 2x squared
times half is just x squared and then
two times the principle square root of
two times one half is just one or it's
just sorry it's just square root of two
it's just one square roots of two so
this whole thing has simplified to
eight plus
x squared all of that over the square
root of two and now let's rationalize
this and the best way to get this
radical out of the denominator is just
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by the principal square root
of 2. so let's do that
so times the principal square root of 2
over the principal square root of 2.
now just to show that it works on the
denominator what is the principal square
root of 2 times the principal square
root of 2 well it's going to be 2.
and in our numerator we have 8 we're
going to distribute this onto both terms
in this expression so you have 8 times
the principal square root of 2
plus
plus the square root of 2 times
times x squared and we can consider this
done we have simplified the expression
or if you want you could break it up you
could say that this is the same thing as
8 square roots of 2 over 2 which is 4
square roots of 2
plus
square root of 2x squared over 2. so
plus square root of 2 over 2
x squared so depending on your tastes
you might view this is more simple or
this is more simple but though both are
equally valid now i said there's
multiple ways to do this we could have
rationalized right from the get-go
let me start with our original problem
so our original problem was 16 plus 2x
squared
all of that over
the principal square root of 8 we could
have rationalized from the get-go by
multiplying the numerator and the
denominator by
the principal square root of 8. multiply
by the principal square root of 8.
and so in our denominator we'll just get
8 and then in our numerator we would get
16 times the principal square root of 8
plus
2 times the principal square root of 8 x
squared and now we can try to simplify
this a little bit more you could say
well everything is divisible by
everything in the numerator and the
denominator is divisible by two so the
16 could become an eight if you divide
by two the two becomes a one and then
this eight becomes a four and then you
get eight square roots of eight plus
square sorry eight square roots of eight
eight square roots of eight plus the
square root of eight
square root of rate eight x squared and
then all of this all of this over four
and you say wait this still looks kind
of different than what we had here and
the reason is we still haven't
simplified this radical we know that we
can rewrite the principal square root of
8 as 2 square roots of 2. this is 2
square roots of 2. and then we can see
again that everything in the numerator
and denominator is also divisible by 2
so let's do that again so if you divide
everything in the numerator by 2 you can
get rid of this 2 that 2 and everything
in the denominator by 2 this will become
a 2. so then you have eight square roots
of two
you have eight square roots of two
plus this got this is just a one now
plus
squares of two x squared all of that
over two which is exactly what we had
gotten here